this is koutu palang the largest refugee
camp in the world there's nearly a
million people here it's located here at
the southern tip of Bangladesh near a
place called Cox's Bazaar the people
here are mostly rohinga Muslims a people
who now have no country that's because
in 2017 the military and citizens in
their Homeland Myanmar forced them out
in a brutal ethnic cleansing that left
thousands dead
their homes and Villages burned to the
[Music]
ground so let me tell you their story
how they ended up here and hopefully
you'll understand why this video is a
fundraiser for these people to try to
lighten their
burden Myanmar is no stranger to
conflict between its many ethnic groups
but the violence that caused the rohinga
to flee their homes that forced a
million people into this refugee camp
was different it was violence that was
fueled by hateful messages and
disinformation inflammatory fake stories
spread by Buddhist nationalists and
extremists and even the military of
Myanmar these messages were spread and
Amplified by one social media platform
that swept the country a western tech
company that hoped to Corner the market
in Mar and profit immensely in this
country a country that was just starting
to use the internet let me show you how
this
happened ultimately this is a story
about misinformation and radicalization
on the internet there are other bad
things that can happen on the internet
and I'm going to pause the story right
now to tell you about the sponsor of
today's video who is in the business of
protecting you online thank you nordvpn
for sponsoring today's video a VPN is a
tool that allows you to connect to the
internet but to select a country through
which you connect to the internet the
other day I was doing all this reporting
on Chinese maps and I was having trouble
for some reason and connected via
Switzerland and it was a lot easier but
that's not a common use case for vpns
mostly people use it if they are in
other countries and they want to connect
to the internet from their own country
so they don't get kicked out of their
like Gmail sometimes I connect to the
internet via Britain so that I can get
access to British Netflix content that
isn't available here but most people use
nordvpn to Simply protect their online
activity it's not just a VPN anymore it
is now a threat protection tool that
allows you to block malware to block
intrusive ads and to generally give you
safety with your data as you surf the
internet and they continue to come out
with new products like they have a
password manager now called nordpass
where you can have all of your passwords
securely stored in this one tool the
internet is a wonderful place but it can
also be a dangerous place increasingly
so and that is why nordvpn exists to
protect you while you're surfing the web
there's a link in my description it is
nordvpn.com Johny Harris when you click
the link it helps support the channel it
also gets you 2 years of
nordvpn plus four extra months you can
try it out you get all your money back
within 30 days if you're not satisfied
it's a good deal and again it helps
support the channel when you sign up
thank you norvan for sponsoring today's
video and supporting our journalism now
let's get back to this very important
story about the internet and Facebook in
Myanmar Myanmar used to be called Burma
and it used to be closed off to the
world for decades it was ruled by
military dictators who kept the country
closed and poor and oppressed the
military dictators belonged to the
Burmese Buddhist majority and had a
particular fixation on marginalizing the
Muslim minority called the rohinga over
the years they stripped the rohinga of
their rights not letting them move
around the country and in the'80s they
passed a law that said that these
rohinga people were not actually Burmy
citizens but then in 2010 in a surprise
move things in Myanmar started changing
myanmar's new dawn has been a long time
coming the Burmese president has hiled a
new chapter in relations with the United
States after Decades of isolation new
leadership came to power and began
opening up the country to the outside
world soon cell phones were flooding
into the country at an astounding rate
jumping from nearly no cell phones in
2006 to 90% penetration by 2016 cell
phone towers started popping up all over
the place connecting the country to the
internet at a Breakneck speed that
internet adoption rate explodes from 1
half of 1% to 40% and I know that might
not sound like a lot if you're in the
United States and everybody is is on the
internet but when you were in a society
where no one is online and suddenly half
of the country is online that is huge
that's my old Vox colleague Max fiser a
journalist who recently wrote a book
about social media algorithms and their
role in stoking extremism in Myanmar and
elsewhere like you go to a village and
there might only be a few people who
have cell phones that have internet
access but those people are relaying
what they're seeing there to everyone
that they're meeting for Venture backed
US tech companies like Facebook looking
for new users this overnight internet
adoption in Myanmar looked like an
opportunity 50 million potential users
who are just coming online for the first
time so Facebook made deals with local
phone providers making it so that
smartphones came pre-loaded with the
Facebook app and that these new internet
users could browse Facebook for free
without using any of their expensive
mobile data more and more people spread
online and alongside that Facebook
rapidly spread throughout the country I
remember that number 40% internet
adoption rate well almost the exact same
proportion the country 38% in 2016 says
that they primarily get their news from
Facebook that's huge 38% is way bigger
than any media source that I can think
of in the United States by this huge
proportion for most people in Myanmar
Facebook was the internet Facebook was
the news and almost immediately videos
like this start showing up I
[Music]
this is ashin Wu a Buddhist monk who is
the leader of the 969 movement it's an
extremist movement that focuses on the
rohinga spreading conspiracy theories
about them how they're invading the
country how they're planning to destroy
the Burmese people watatu called himself
the Burmese Bin Laden and he made a
career out out of becoming an anti-
ringia preacher one of his main methods
was always paper pamphlets and leaflets
he would distribute these throughout the
country to spread his lies and his
conspiracies about the rohinga but in
2003 he was sentenced to 25 years in
prison for all of this hate speech but
he was released early in 2012 right as
Myanmar was changing opening up becoming
connected to the internet as Wu entered
burmes Society he found a new tool to
spread his anti- ringa messages an
algorithm designed to serve users
content that will engage them that will
outrage them that will keep them on the
platform for as long as possible so that
a tech company in California can sell
ads and make money so the thing that the
Facebook algorithm learns to promote in
Myanmar very quickly is hatred of the
Muslim minority over the next few years
weu found a home for his hate speech on
Facebook and YouTube but mostly Facebook
which had quickly become the country's
favorite social media platform this
significantly Amplified his reach to
hundreds of thousands of Facebook users
in the
country and he was just one of many
spreading lies and conspiracies about
the rohinga heat speech conspiracies and
incitements to violence all directed at
the country's Muslim minority are just
overrunning the platform over the next 5
years tension between the Burmese
Buddhist majority and the rohinga Muslim
minority turn more and more violent as
the country grapples with the rapid
change in economic growth associated
with opening up to the world this
tension and racism in no way was caused
by Facebook but it was on Facebook that
a troubling pattern started to
emerge somewhere in the country there's
a crime it's allegedly committed by some
rohinga person like the alleged assault
assault and murder of a Burmese Woman by
a group of rohinga men news of the crime
spreads like wildfire some of it making
it onto social media remember Facebook
was the news for many people and of
course we all know what happens on the
internet as it spreads the story changes
conspiracies emerge that the rohinga are
stockpiling weapons or that they are
actually foreign Invaders and that
they're planning to take over anti-
rohinga voices with big followings chime
in saying that this is proof of what
they've been saying all along the
rohinga are planning to take over the
country and they must be expelled and
soon the fight goes from social media to
the doorsteps of the rohinga people
themselves a state of emergency has been
declared in Western Burma where deadly
clashes between Buddhists and Muslims
have killed at least 17 people hundreds
of homes were set Al light the first
massive outbreak of violence in this era
happened in 2012 we're burning Ring's
houses because they live near our
village and they gather at night and try
to attack us ordinary Burmese citizens
heed the call raiding rohinga Villages
and burning them to the
ground the security forces had to step
in but not to stop the violence instead
to help the destruction Witnesses report
that the security forces wouldn't let
the rohinga extinguish the fire that was
burning down their houses even when they
tried they just stood by and let it
happen from this 2012 incident which is
kind of the beginning of our story the
government officially reported that 192
people were killed 86 00 homes destroyed
but experts say that the numbers are
almost certainly much higher 140,000
rohinga were forced to leave their home
many fleeing to neighboring
Bangladesh Facebook didn't play a huge
role in this first major outbreak of
violence back in 2012 the platform was
new and just getting started but this
pattern of conspiracies and rumors
spreading on the platform and then
leading to real world violence that
pattern continued to grow as more and
more people got on Facebook and soon it
would play a role in helping Buddhist
extremists commit what many call
[Music]
genocide so where's Facebook the company
in all of this there was this journalist
and digital researcher Ella Kellen was
in Myanmar conducting research on a
Stanford Fellowship looking into hate
speech online and she's seen this
pattern emerge she's so alarmed she
flies all the way back to Silicon Valley
to meet with people at Facebook to say
hey this is really dangerous it's really
bad it turns out she learns in that
meeting that Facebook has exactly one
moderator who speaks burmes which is one
of the many languages spoken in myammar
which basically means it's entirely
ungoverned Ken attempts to sound the
alarm she's warning them in this meeting
with Facebook Executives this is really
dangerous what you were doing is really
destabilizing for this country at a
really fragile and really tenuous moment
and they basically do nothing and this
happens over and over again in the 4
years between when Facebook arrives in
Myanmar and when the genocide
starts this was a part of a larger Trend
not just from Facebook but the whole
International Community they didn't want
to focus on the dark side of what was
going on in Myanmar they wanted to focus
on the positive aspects myanmar's
miraculous and sudden opening up to the
world the world's attitude is hey this
was a extreme authoritarian military
dictatorship closed off from the outside
world that is opening up they're having
elections they're having democracy
they're turning away from China towards
the West isn't this great just a month
after this first spat of violence
President Obama visits Myanmar and meets
with the government foreign companies
continue to invest in the economy of
Myanmar and Facebook's presence as a key
source of information continues to
spread but under the surface in the
algorithmic feeds of millions of users
hate and conspiracy was being rewarded
with attention the algorithm feeding it
to more and more users enraging them
inflaming them confirming their beliefs
and their biases according to Human
Rights campaigners 20 Muslim Students
were murdered here in March when
religious violence swept through this
city in central Myanmar Wu's audience
kept growing into the hundreds of
thousands his speeches reaching a larger
and larger audience in the patter
continued in the town of mtila an
argument in a muslim-owned gold shop
turned into a brawl leaving a Buddhist
man injured Buddhist extremists post
inciting messages on Facebook saying
that more attacks are coming that the
rohinga are
dangerous and once again what started in
the news feed turns into a violent
Buddhist mob roaming the streets forcing
people out of their homes burning
mosques to the ground killing dozens and
once again the security Security Forces
largely stand by allowing another
massacre in fact the military starts to
participate in a new way restricting the
movement of the rohinga forcing them
into camps and not letting them
leave in response to these conditions
some rohinga form an Insurgency group
and start fighting back but they're
totally outmatched extremism on Facebook
continues to grow and in March of 2014
Ellen once again makes the trip to
Silicon Valley to deliver a warning hate
speech and disinformation are spreading
on the platform and it will lead to
violence but once again Facebook did
nothing they still only had one burmes
Speaking moderator who wasn't even in
the country who was expected to keep all
of this under control and sure enough a
few months later wiu uses Facebook to
Target a Muslim tea shop telling lies
about the owners and giving his
followers their name and address
hundreds of followers take to the street
burning down Muslim owned businesses and
killing two the violence mostly
targeting the minority rohinga Community
has killed more than 200 people and made
140,000 hopeless Facebook still wouldn't
step in so the Myanmar government had to
they blocked Facebook in the city of
Mandalay where the violence was
happening it was the strongest warning
yet that Facebook was indeed driving
violence in the country this and more
warnings from experts was a wakeup call
but Facebook only ends up making
promises but takes no aggressive action
to stop hate speech on their platform
and they continue to focus what they're
good at growth and expansion the thing
that will make them
money in 2016 a think tank in Washington
DC releases a report that analyzes
32,000 Facebook accounts in Myanmar
these were accounts of everyday users
and the report found that these accounts
were overwhelmed with hateful messages
against the
rohinga and just when you think that
Facebook's enabling role couldn't get
any worse the milit of Myanmar joins the
platform they create Pages pretending to
be news sites or beauty and lifestyle
Pages they gain huge followings and then
they sprinkle in propaganda they amplify
the tensions between Buddhists and
rohinga they post graphic photos of
corpses saying that the rohinga were
attacking that jihadist attacks would be
carried out any day and the conspiracies
kept getting more and more extreme oh
yeah the Muslims in my Village are
stockpiling guns at the beest of Saudi
Arabia and and they're they're going to
take over unless we go and kill them
first and it would get thousands of
shares so what we're looking at is
Facebook not just amplifying hate speech
posted by the average citizen or by
extremists but the platform being used
as a tool of psychological warfare by a
military trying to create fear and
mistrust in its own people it was a
giant escalating mob hatred towards the
rohinga which wasn't new in Myanmar
these ethnic tensions go back decades
but it was different now because the mob
in this case wasn't just someone's
Village or Community it was the entire
country being viewed through the lens of
a technology that serves up the most
extreme and engaging content that
polarizes in the name of Engagement it
was a ticking Time Bomb one that went
off in 2016 and
[Music]
2017 because the rohinga insurgents were
fighting back in 2016 the military
starts performing what they call
clearance operations going Village to
Village burning down homes and driving
the rohinga out these clearance
operations lead to the death of hundreds
of rohinga 990,000 more people are
forced to flee their home over the
border to a refugee camp in Bangladesh
and once again they meet little to no
push back from their government or the
International Community they now had a
Playbook it was a new level of violence
not just from the polarized people but
now from the military itself seeing this
violence break out in early 2017 d David
Madden who ran a tech startup in Myanmar
traveled to Facebook headquarters to
give them a final warning that their
platform is spreading hate and that the
situation in Myanmar is getting really
bad this was his second time delivering
such a warning but like all the others
before him he was ignored a few months
later it's the summer of 2017 and watatu
is ated again visiting rakine state
where the rohinga live delivering one of
his signature hateful sermons which is
being Amplified by local media and of
course his Following on Facebook the
next month rohinga insurgents launch
another attack on security forces in
rakine state the attacks lead to 12
security Personnel
[Music]
deaths and this was the final
justification that the military was
looking for to do what they had been
planning and plotting for years it
happened quickly and violently armed men
marched from Village to Village across
rine state in one of these clearance
operations they were joined by civilians
feeling more justified in their racism
than ever it's a chilling and detailed
account of what can only be described as
a premeditated Massacre and together the
military and the civilians kicked down
doors they burned down homes and mosques
they killed indiscriminately committing
horrific acts of violence the Rampage
was widespread and systematic theja
villagers had fled in Terror when troops
and their own Buddhist neighbor
rampaged into chenar and then torched
it hundreds of villages burned to the
ground this Geo dat obtained through
satellite imagery shows the areas that
were burned and destroyed by this
extermination campaign and it helps us
see just how widespread this was it was
Swift and violent it was systematic and
it was an effort Led Out by the military
and joined by local people who had been
radicalized for years by anti- ringia
prop propaganda more and more of it
being spread throughout the country by
the unmonitored algorithms of
[Music]
Facebook tens of thousands of rohinga
killed and over 700,000 fleeing for
their lives ending up in a refugee camp
in
Bangladesh to outside observers this
event might have looked like spontaneous
violence but this was actually the
result of a coordinated campaign by a
few key people with access to technology
that allowed them to reach Millions to
lie to them in the most hateful ways to
warp their realities it was a full-scale
ethnic cleansing and it was in part
fueled and enabled by an ungoverned
social media
platform even after the violence the
Burmese military continued to use
Facebook writing one post that said that
the rohinga problem had actually been an
unfinished job that had finally been
solved and by solved he means the
organized murder of tens of thousands of
innocent people and the forced expulsion
of almost a million of them the UN would
refer to this campaign as a textbook
example of ethnic cleansing others used
the word genocide and only after this
horrific event did Facebook actually
respond it wasn't until 2018 when they
finally took down the pages of senior
military officials who were spreading
lies and calls to violence on their
platform the UN came in to investigate
how this happened how another genocide
happened on our watch They concluded
that Facebook had been quote a useful
instrument for those seeking to spread
hate they also noted that Facebook
declined to share with them data that
would have helped with their
[Music]
investigation in 2021 these military
leaders who were responsible for this
ethnic cleansing of the rohinga people
they took over the country again they
removed the elected government and yet
another coup koutu palang the refugee
camp in Bangladesh now holds over 1
million people most of them rohinga
fleeing the violence in their home
country the government of Bangladesh
wants to return them to Myanmar but
International observers and the rohinga
themselves say that there's no way they
could do that safely after all the
government in power is the one that
massacred them returning to Myanmar now
would be more dangerous than ever so
they sit in their refugee camp without a
country and without support which is why
we are raising as much money as we can
to support them Facebook claims that
they changed their practices since the
massacre of 2017 but in 2022 just last
year Global witness did an investigation
and they were able to place ads on
Facebook that contained hateful messages
in the Burmese language Facebook didn't
reject any of those ads whereas here in
the United States or in Brazil Facebook
seems to have real controls for hateful
ads but it appears not in Myanmar even
after all this this story in some ways
is specific to me Myanmar it's a country
that had been closed off to the world
for a long time it opened up it was
newly connected to the internet and soon
long-standing tensions between ethnic
groups exploded but in other ways this
is a story about humans everywhere about
how we've chosen to build our society
around technology and social media
platforms that are supposed to connect
us and they do and yet in the process
we've learned just how much they also
create division spread disinformation
and limit our ability to live in a
shared reality it's a story about how
that process that trade-off can have
deadly
[Music]
consequences